ce film nous a réunis
c'était nécessaire pour nous et c'est
très beau et je te remercie du fond mon
père
je t'aime
merci
c'est trop beau sexe et caméras là
franchement je fais pas trop attention
là cela je suis concentré sur
mon tapis pour fabien avocat ligne et
ouais et même on est plus l'espèce est
plus photographiée dans le monde
[Musique]
va venir m'embrasser où
c'est après ce qui s'est passé dans le
couple là c'était très émouvant le
baiser donc je vienne
ces femmes cinéma robert pattinson qui a
été sacrée plus bel homme du monde grâce
au nombre d'or le nombre de requêtes que
c'est en fait lors en effet le visage en
parfaite harmonie répondant à des
critères géométriques idéaux il est
suivi de très près dans ce classement
par l'acteur henry cavill puis bradley
cooper puis brad pitt puis david pujadas
[Rires]
les
emmerdes
vous devrez donner à patrick octobre il
est connu pour son adresse enlever ça
vous allez prendre et ça ça serait comme
ça ça oui allez on y va pardon
sylvie testud elle a appris aussi à
sabrer le fourneau à lennon et que vous
chauffez de moi je ne faut casser les
oeufs
tu sais faire
référencer viol non c'est julian je sens
que ça va être spectacle 16e pourquoi je
veux pas qu'ils cassaient je le sais je
sais
[Musique]
c'est une expérience d'une catastrophe
cherchent de truc c'est pas grave à mon
avis elle mais elle n'a pas eu drones
c'est pas vrai
c'est sur l'eau pas exactement bon j'y
arrive pas bon j'y arrive pas c'est pas
grave alliés de ces recherches ce qui
compte c'est qu'ils y ait 1600 attendez
j'ai croisé un jeune garçon et il me dit
mais tu vas une serrure et qui alors je
vais dit tom hanks et me dit mais c'est
une star tom hanks je savais pas quoi
lui répondre je lui ai dit quoi je rêve
j'aurais dû lui répondre
alors je suis arrivé dans match et nord
sas et l'autre tom kitt arrivait pas jet
privé
j'espère que
j'espère qu'il dira ah c'est un acteur
qui me les vêtements de quelqu'un
d'autre qui fait semblant d'être
quelqu'un d'autre c'est ça mon boulot
ça marche pas désolé c'est le fait chez
nous foute ya des prolongations
gas on fait gaffe n'attend que ça parte
pas dans la chine elle ne veut y arriver
michael prudent
et on voit les mec courageux il sait
regarder gregorio
le mot cancer c'est vraiment quand on
sert les émotions à l'intérieur par un
jaune tumeur dit tu dis pas mais au delà
des jeux de mots le pas qui tient un
discours beaucoup plus radical sur les
réseaux sociaux vous apporter on
n'attrape l'embryon et on vend les
cellules foetales non seulement avec le
vaccin qui voulait mettre dans les
vaccins mais la coca cola et c'est bien
parce que ça améliore le goût des
aliments réfléchissez un peu quand vous
dormez vous ne travaillez pas vous
produisez rien et vous ne consommez pas
vous n'achetez rien donc c'est très
ennuyeux les gens qui dort il faut
absolument
raccourcir leur temps de sommeil
augmenter leur temps de productivité ou
de consommation c'est ce que sont en
train de réussir à faire les écrans et
tout ce qui est littérature roman tout
ça vous plaît l'austère qu à burke assez
chic pendant ces stages christian telle
chaleur n'hésite pas à prendre
l'apparence d'un dictateur pour
transmettre son message anti médecine
je suis le docteur stumpf le problème
dans votre vie ce sont les russes qui
vous attaque si méchante petite bête et
nous avec l'industrie pharmaceutique
nous allons faire la planète propre
bon je vous en conjure si jamais vous
voyez ce dock challenge juillet vous
étes trés voit d'ailleurs chez vous
boire l'eau mais un peu de minéral c'est
un peu ça c'est bien ça vous va bien
parce qu'on est très ancrée d'accord
c'est mes racines c'est mon cerveau et
dont les tiges
à vos dans les pieds au moment où vous
l'avez trouvée
[Rires]